[Musique]
c'est le project the beaches des
étudiants en master m1 et m2 est ici a
dit mme catherine traction et de m2
interactions de l'université paris
saclay est ici présente les travaux
qu'ils ont fait pour les cours de
creative design des shows fabrication
fabrication numérique mixte entre djibo
leity et design project
donc ce sont des projets qui sont
créatifs et ce sont des projets où les
étudiants s'exprime au travers du médium
qui est l'interaction et détecter les
nouvelles technologies c'est des projets
qui sont innovants et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on les pousse à participer
à cette exposition et à confronter leurs
idées à du vrai public et avoir un truc
comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent affecter
les gens à travers les travaux qu'ils
ont fait et donc ça à chaque fois un
grand plaisir d'accueillir du public et
de vous voir comment est-ce que les gens
interagissent avec les étudiants leur
donne des feedback sur leurs projets
c'est aussi une innovation pédagogique
puisque c'est à travers cette exposition
là qu'on évalue les projets des
étudiants et on considère qu'un projet
n'est tabou tiko lorsqu'il est capable
de confronter à un public réel et de
vraiment existé dans la vraie vie ce
sont des étudiants qui viennent de
partout dans le monde
il ya des étudiants français notamment
m2 interactions des master m1 et m2 hci
défaut partie de l'élite et digital qui
est un ensemble de ne heurter un qui
délivre ce master là et qui finançait
par l'union européenne
les étudiants passent une année chez
nous et une année dans un autre noeud
qui peut être avec city madrid berlin
ci dessous la spécificité de cette année
c'est qu'on l'a organisée au proto 204
on est très contents d'être là puisque
c'est vraiment un lieu de rencontre et
un lieu ouvert à la communauté aux
chercheurs aux étudiants aux différentes
personnes qui constituent paris saclay
on voulait le faire ici aussi pour
pouvoir ouvrir justement cette
exposition un plus large public et faire
rencontrer des étudiants différentes
filières différentes personnes qui font
partie de paris saclay différents
laboratoires même voire même des
entreprises du plateau et on sent que
que ça a pris et que justement on a pu
peut-être mobilisé 1
plus de gens de l'extérieur et que nous
mêmes on est sorti de notre laboratoire
on est allé présenter nos travaux à
l'extérieur de notre chez nous donc on
est très contentes de sap
[Musique]